today's question comes from jessica in
washington state
jessica writes i'm a full-time mom with
three children
my husband's job allows no time for him
to finish
uh allows no time for him to give me a
break i'm one class away from a master's
degree and i can't even find time to
finish
we cannot afford child care how can i
find fulfillment and avoid becoming
bitter this sounds like a multi
there's a lot in this question dave
mm-hmm
um i've been through seasons where
obviously my wife's and i both had
graduate degrees we had a young kid we
were trying to finish those and racing
get done
and there was times we had to trade
certain things for child care we had to
get really creative with having somebody
come over and help out or folks from
where we worked or folks from school um
folks from church but
when we had to figure it out we figured
it out and unless somebody's uh they may
be out on an island here so i don't want
to doubt jessica has gone to what she
can
gone to the ends to figure it out but it
sounds like she's got a challenge with
her husband's job
which below that is she's got a
challenge with her husband that's what i
heard
yeah um because listen i
we've been through seasons here when i
started this business i was working
16 hours a day right sharon will tell
you she was like a single mom
and uh and when i think about that
situation
if we had sat down with three kids and
she's at home full-time
and i'm gone all the time i mean i was
teaching financial peace i'm on the
radio i'm traveling i'm speaking i'm
you know launching books i mean it was
about a two-year period of time
that i was leave before dark and come
home after dark i mean it was just
yeah i was working to get a business off
the ground and we were in agreement on
that
she was not embittered by that but if in
that setting
as hard as i was turning it on if she
had said i'm
one class from a master's degree
this is pissing me off i want to finish
it
we would have figured figured out a way
to adjust old daves
that's right uh schedule uh
because i love my wife and and that is a
i mean if you want to go to back to
school for four years that's a different
equation you're
one class that's why something else and
you can't smell
he can't figure out a way to adjust his
job on that
ever in the foreseeable future i call bs
i i call well and the other side of it
is how can you find
fulfillment and avoid becoming bitter
you can't be fulfilled if you're in a
one-sided relationship
where somebody is not willing to sit
down and and have this conversation with
you
well i'm not sure their master's degree
makes you fulfilled i'm not sure even
getting a master's degree and going into
a career is going to make the
relationship issue here but this is um
uh it's not i don't know if i i'll just
take fulfillment out of it i'll just be
bitter
[Laughter]
i mean come on bubba figure this out man
that's uh that's a husband problem
that's that's what old dave's reading
into that i'm not sure
it well yeah just jessica's it's
do you find this that people like to
blame the job
and not the the employer employee
there's been seasons where i think it
was easier for
me to get frustrated with my wife's
employer or her to get him frustrated
with my wife's employ
with my employer than to sit down and
say
hey john you're choosing work over us
yeah
yeah i mean it's yeah i mean if you
because here's the thing um
if he is in a good career in a positive
situation
he's getting a ton of attaboys and
affirmations
and he wants to stay there and get more
of those instead of come home
with somebody who's bitter and
unfulfilled
and exhausted from watching three kids
all day but yeah but i mean yeah
he's like a hero there when he comes
home he's a dog so i mean i i don't know
i'm not blaming her either i'm just
saying
uh or you know he's just self-centered
jerk i don't know
i don't know what's going on what i can
tell you is bitterness
is the the the paved road to resentment
and you don't come back from resentment
so this couple needs to throw a flag
turn all the lights on in the house and
say we got to stop this right now i
agree
i agree yeah and i i mean it might be
because here's the thing too
maybe there's he's in a situation where
for the next 12 months he's gonna have
to do this and it's all seasonal right
yeah
but but when it's this all feels like
it's fatalistic it's forever
right and uh and that's what our that's
what's
setting our both of our signals off yeah
we got flares going off all around our
brains right now
but the uh uh but if you go well for the
next 12 months
he's going to have to turn it on but
then i'll be able to take my class
then you can not be better because you
can see your your chance of finishing
this up
and that's a reasonable ask but that's a
couple coming together like a budget
right and saying it's going to take us
this much a month yeah to pay this off
in this
but there's an end to it right because
you know but but if this is like for the
next 10 years it's just his job i just
have to put up with it
that's that's so fatalistic right that's
just that's the wrong way to look at it
there's
because nothing is that solid nothing
stays in place that long